members continue debating EU reform with  European leaders Italy's Prime Minister  Giuseppe Conte takes his turn to present  his views on the future of Europe  members are voting on a free-trade  agreement between the EU and Singapore  it will eliminate virtually all tariffs  within five years protect unique  European products and open up  Singapore's procurement market to EU  companies millions of animals travel  each year inside and outside the EU for  breeding or slaughtering members are  discussing ways to improve livestock  welfare and reduce journey times members  vote on setting up the first EU level  tool to screen foreign direct investment  on grounds of security to protect  critical infrastructure such as water  and transport key technologies and  communications water scarcity in the EU  is increasing members vote on measures  to better manage and reuse water to  reduce the over exploitation of  resources  [Music]